das hier könnt ihr jede nacht sehen wenn
ihr in den sternenhimmel schaut kein
witz das ist alles wirklich da nur
leider kann unser menschliches auge dass
nicht alles wahrnehmen und das ist
schade denn in diesen ganzen gewusel
stecken wahnsinnig viele informationen
und vielleicht sogar der schlüssel zur
dunklen materie
jetzt gab es einen großen durchbruch und
deswegen wollen wir uns heute mal
anschauen wie wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler das was uns jahrtausende
lang verborgen blieb nun endlich
sichtbar machen
[Musik]
denn ist der turm
unser menschliches auge hat einen
nachteil so genial es auch ist es sieht
nur einen kleinen wellenlängenbereich
des lichts alles was du jemals mit
eigenen augen gesehen hast lag ungefähr
zwischen 390 und 780 nanometern alle
anderen wellenlängen können wir nicht
sehen auch wenn wir ständig von ihnen
umgeben sind und das ist ja eigentlich
ziemlich traurig unser universum ist
voll mit spannenden faszinierenden und
auch verwirrendem zeugs und wir können
nur einen bruchteil davon sehen doch die
wissenschaft hat eine lösung und zwar
röntgenstrahlen die gleichen strahlen
mit denen wir in unserem körper
hineinsehen können kommen nämlich auch
aus dem weltall zu uns aber warum können
röntgenstrahlen eigentlich so viel mehr
enthüllen als normales licht und wie
funktioniert das ganze mittels röntgen
teleskopen können wir hoch energetische
prozesse im universum beobachten also
quasi alles wo es so richtig zur sache
geht so können wir zum beispiel
untersuchen was aus dem ersten von
supernovae wird welche eigenschaften die
magnetfelder von sternen haben oder was
passiert wenn ein stern von einem
anderen war sie aufgesaugt wird vor
allem können wir aber die heißen gase
zwischen sternen untersuchen die wiegen
etwa fünf bis zehn mal mehr als alle
sichtbaren sterne zusammen da draußen
gibt es also eine riesige unbekannte
welt die für normale teleskope teilweise
unsichtbar ist in diese sehr sehr dünnen
heißen gase die fast einem vakuum ähneln
geben deutlich mehr röntgenstrahlung ab
als sichtbares licht mittels und in
teleskopen können wir die gase nicht nur
überhaupt entdecken sondern auch sehen
wie heiß sie sind wie dicht sie sind und
aus welchen elementen sie bestehen
besonders interessant für die
forschenden ist wie die gase sich
bewegen so können wir die großräumigen
strukturen des universums nachvollziehen
und wir können untersuchen wie sich
unser universum gerade aus den tvi es
expandiert und hofft sogar endlich
herauszufinden was denn diese verflixte
dunkle materie eigentlich genau ist kurz
zum auffrischen falls ihr da nicht up to
date sein die meisten expertinnen und
experten glauben dass unerklärliche
gravitations phänomene im weltall auf
bisher unentdeckte
dunkle materie zurückzuführen ist und
dunkel heißt in dem kontext einfach nur
dass wir nicht wirklich wissen was es
ist aber mit herkömmlichen teleskopen
können wir nichts dergleichen sehen die
hoffnung auf die röntgenstrahlung kommt
jetzt daher dass eines der teilchen aus
der die dunkle materie möglicherweise
bestehen könnte theoretisch
röntgenstrahlung ausstrahlen müsste und
genau danach sucht man jetzt gerade nach
dieser speziellen röntgenstrahlung würde
man diese strahlen finden dann hätte man
einen großen hinweis darauf ob dunkle
materie wirklich materie ist und aus was
sie besteht unter anderem deshalb sind
die neuesten entwicklungen so ein großer
durchbruch vor zwei jahren machte das
neue röntgenteleskop e rosita seine
erste vollständige aufnahme des gesamten
himmels im röntgenlicht die letzte
durchmusterungen hatte eine deutlich
geringere aufnahmequalität zahl der
bekannten röntgenquellen hat sich in
dieser neuen karte ungefähr verdoppelt
und mit vier mal mehr tiefe verzeichnet
sie auch viele neue objekte die in der
30 jahre alten vorgänger karte noch gar
nicht zu sehen waren sieben neue
himmelskarte soll rosetta in den
nächsten jahren liefern und genau wie
die erde einmal kartografiert und
dadurch besser verstanden haben
kartografieren dir jetzt auch stück für
stück unser universum und diese
gigantische vermessung bildet die
grundlage für viele jahrzehnte weiterer
forschungen doch damit wie die
unsichtbare seite unseres universums
sichtbar machen können mussten einige
schwierige herausforderungen überwunden
werden übrigens wenn ihr diese
unsichtbare seite unseres universums
einmal selber sehen wollt dann könnt ihr
das beim festival highlights der physik
tun und zwar vom 27 september bis zum 2
oktober in würzburg mit verschiedenen
angeboten wird da unter anderem der
geburtstag von wilhelm conrad röntgen
nachgefeiert der uns zu diesem video
hier inspiriert hat aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles es gibt auch die große
highlight show mit ranga yogeshwar
es gibt eine riesige themen ausstellung
mit über 35 exponaten wo ihr viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mit fragen löchern können zu viel
gewollt und es gibt einen
schülerwettbewerb sowie ein
abschlusskonzert am samstag den 2 in der
s oliver-arena
inhaltlich kann ich auch schon mal
verraten dass es unter anderem um
laserstrahlen um treibhausgase um
quantencomputer und vieles vieles mehr
gehen wird und egal ob von zu hause oder
vor ort in pittsburgh
könnt auf jeden fall dabei sein denn das
beste ist sowohl online auf youtube als
auch in würzburg ist der eintritt
komplett kostenlose teilweise müsst ihr
euch vorher online anmelden und für die
shows und für die vorträge sind
eintrittskarten erforderlich aber alles
weitere findet ihr auf www punkt
highlights music.de oder über die links
in der video beschreibung ich bin auf
jeden fall am dienstag den 28 september
in würzburg vor ort und werde euch auf
dem instagram kanal at highlights der
physik alles zeigen was die
veranstaltung so zu bieten hat und
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja dann vor ort
okay aber jetzt erst mal wieder zurück
zum thema und der frage was hat die
vermessung per röntgenstrahlung zu
schwierig gemacht das grundprinzip ist
er eigentlich relativ einfach die
objekte die wir beobachten wollen sind
röntgenstrahlung aus und die müssen wir
eigentlich nur einfach klingt simpel ist
es aber wie so oft nicht die erste
herausforderung ist dass wir raus aus
der atmosphäre müssen denn die
absolviert den größten teil der
kosmischen röntgenstrahlung wir müssen
also im gegensatz zu normalen teleskopen
für sichtbares licht eine rakete ins
weltall schicken nur um ein paar bilder
zu bekommen und deswegen wurde auch erst
1962 die erste strahlungsquelle mit
einem röntgenteleskop beobachtet das
übrigens von kenia aus ins all startete
der musiker hat die neue sonde des max
planck instituts für extraterrestrische
physik des dlr und der russischen
weltraumagentur roskosmos steht
beispielsweise am 2 der sogenannten
lagrange punkte der erde hier halten
sich die gravitationskräfte der
verschiedenen himmelskörper die waage
das heißt dass der satellit bis auf
kleine korrektur manöver ganz ohne
antrieb in der gleichen distanz zur erde
verharren kann und gemeinsam mit ihr um
die sonne kreist eine zweite
herausforderung ist die tatsache dass
röntgenstrahlen sehr schwierig
einzufangen sind durch gewöhnliche
spiegel fliegen sie nämlich einfach
hindurch weil ihre wellenlänge von unter
zehn nanometern so kurz ist das
röntgenteleskop müssen mit anderen
materialien und speziellen sehr flachen
einfallswinkel arbeiten damit die
röntgenstrahlen nicht einfach wieder
abhauen das ist wie wenn man einen stein
über das wasser springen lassen möchte
das geht nur wenn er das wasser ganz
flach streift wenn er nicht flach genug
auftritt dann fällt er einfach durch die
wasseroberfläche
durch der satellit rosetta verwendet zb
extrem glatte gold beschichtete
oberflächen das sind ja eigentlich ganz
schick software oder vielleicht auch was
für unser studio oder gold beschichtet
der spiegel der kostet 90 millionen euro
ok dann vielleicht doch besser nicht
naja wenn wir die strahlen dann endlich
eingefangen haben sind aber noch nicht
alle probleme gelöst und damit kommen
wir zu einem weiteren großen knackpunkt
der datenübertragung vom satelliten zur
erde die aufnahmen der teleskope müssen
nämlich beim täglichen downlink
teilweise das vierfache der distanz
zwischen mond und erde zurück legen und
es muss immer eine empfangsstation auf
der erdhälfte sein die dem satelliten
gerade zugewandt ist für aero sie da zum
beispiel wurde extra eine neue station
am äußersten zipfel von russland gebaut
um den datendownload sicherzustellen
okay aber wie geht es denn jetzt weiter
die ganzen neuen objekte und phänomene
die musiker gefunden hat liefern stoff
für jahre voller detaillierter
untersuchungen das heißt der nächste
punkt auf der forschungsagenda ist nun
erneut die verbesserung der
empfindlichkeit und auflösung der
röntgenteleskop damit diese neuen
objekte ausführlich untersucht werden
können aber so alt wie unser universum
bisher schon ist haben wir da noch ein
ganz klein bisschen zeit ich bin auf
jeden fall schon sehr gespannt was mit
röntgen teleskopen alles noch in den
nächsten jahren entdecken werden wenn
wir zum beispiel der dunklen materie
endlich mal auf die schliche kommen
würden dann wäre das ein riesiger
durchbruch in der physik aber jetzt bin
ich mal auf eure meinung gespannt findet
ihr es auch so spooky das um uns herum
materie da sie herum schwirren die wir
gar nicht sehen können schreibt mir das
gerne mal in die kommentare ansonsten
sehen wir es vielleicht in würzburg bei
highlights der physik mich wird es auf
jeden fall freuen wie immer 400 fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick